[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 16 décembre bienvenue dans
le 7-8 journal de la rédaction de tv
60,18 voici les titres de cette édition
élu pour la première fois en 2012 elle
brigue un troisième mandat josé fille
coleman ce berger sera bien candidate
aux municipales à plaisir la maire
sortante a lancé sa campagne en fin de
semaine dernière
noël à un moment festif qui peut virer
au drame entre illuminations du sapin
utilisation des bougies et surcharges
électriques les risques d'incendié sont
nombreux en cette période tous les
conseils pour éviter les incidents avec
le lieutenant colonel sébastien frémont
du sud 10 78 et puis découverte de ce
nouveau lieu culturel à versailles la
fontaine implantée au coeur des carré
saint-louis devient le cube un espace
dédié aux expositions notamment de bande
dessinée avec un focus en ce moment sur
antoine de saint-exupéry et tout à
l'heure dans ce journal
également ce qu'il faut retenir des
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département le deuxième jour de grève
contre la réforme des retraites les
perturbations étaient nombreux ce matin
regarder cette carte et du réseau
sytadin 6h47 déjà 330 km de bouchons
cumulés en ile de france le pic de la
matinée a été enregistré à plus de 600
km de trafic dans la région
presqu'autant que lundi dernier qui
reste le record de l'année en la matière
et galère aussi dans les transports en
commun et notamment sur le réseau stibus
qui dessert l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines vous allez peut-être
le voir sur ces images ça y est à
l'initiative de la cgt cheminots le
dépôt des cars à trappes a été bloqué en
début de journée résultat un trafic
perturbé dès 7 heures du matin avec une
reprise progressive
un peu avant 10 heures et demain ça ne
risque de ne pas s'arranger une nouvelle
mobilisation est prévue dans les rues de
paris à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
dans les organisations réformistes et de
la cfdt la cftc et l'unsa qui se sont
jointes au mouvement
restez avec nous à la fin de ce journal
le point sur vos conditions de
circulation dans les transports en
commun pour cette journée de mardi
elle se lance donc pour un troisième
mandat l'actuel maire de plaisir
joséphine coleman ce berger a annoncé sa
candidature vendredi
et pour les élections municipales de
2020 entre la défense de 2,2 ce bilan
est à propositions de nouveaux projets
elle présente une liste d'ouverture
politique
nicolas landry la presse locale invité
dans sa permanence pour l' annonce de sa
candidature la mère de plaisir joséphine
coleman ce berger se lance dans la
campagne pour les municipales
objectif briguer un troisième mandat
après avoir été élu maire en 2012 et sa
réélection en 2014
il ya un bilan important qui a été fait
par l'ensemble des équipes sur une
mandature complète et ce bilan mérite
aujourd'hui je pense véritablement
d'être continuer nous avons mis en place
deux grands projets qui sont des projets
structurants de la collectivité
cette dynamique il faut la continuer
mais en même temps on a entendu que ce
désir de bien-être de ville nature de
ville humaine de ville également
entreprenante et puis de ville aussi
responsable tous ces mots ce sont des
mots former des mots que l'on retrouve
aujourd'hui dans une vraie volonté de
notre population ville nature humaine
est responsable et entreprenante les
quatre axes du projet de la candidate en
cours de finition sa liste déjà complète
sera renouvelée à 50 % par rapport à
autour de moi j'ai une série de
personnes qui sont très divers et variés
des non inscrits et aussi des personnes
qui vont dans divers mouvements qui
aujourd'hui se sont rapprochés de nous
et nous avons une ouverture totale à
divers mouvements les plus jeunes en
vingt ans déjà
on a énormément de personnes entre 20 et
35 ans ont aussi rendu compte en en
regroupant toutes ces personnes qui
avaient des personnes qui étaient
représentatifs de tous les quartiers de
la ville et dieu sait si plaisir est
grand
la liste et le programme seront
présentées au mois de janvier 2000 vain
pour le moment face à l patrick jeantet
rex membre de la majorité municipale
s'est lancée avec une liste intitulée
remettons plaisir en marche
avoir confiance en son équipe gérer des
situations de stress des cas de figure
que connaissent les chefs d'entreprise
mais aussi et les pilotes de chasse des
liens développés la semaine dernière
dans une conférence assurée par bertrand
nivard l'ancien leader de la patrouille
de france était l'invité du medef des
yvelines mélanie poquet et nicolas
landry l'armée de l'air bertrand
varla connu pendant 16 ans 3000 heures
de vol dont plusieurs comme leader de la
patrouille de france
une expérience qu'il met en parallèle
avec le rôle d'un chef d'entreprise
celui qui donne un peu la cadence la
musique
il doit faire preuve d'innovation et
créatif et puis susciter l'adhésion donc
c'est une classe assez difficile
aujourd'hui pilote de nine sur a320
après un passage dans la sécurité civile
il était invité par le medef yvelines a
partagé son expérience valeurs humaines
confiance en les autres membres de
l'équipe pilotes et mécaniciens peut pas
régler a fait avec le monde de
l'entreprise et le chef d'entreprise il
est il est évident le chef d'entreprise
il est là pour fédérer
alors il est là pour fédérer son équipe
il est aussi pour fédérer ces clients là
pour fédérer un ton bon de un tas de
monde autour de lui qui est susceptible
en fait de de réussir sa mission est
aussi le chef d'entreprise
accessoirement il a un peu à ce sujet au
stress donc ils avaient aussi besoin
d'avoir d'autres expériences
une conférence pour parler aussi de
l'esprit de performance une notion qui
importe à la section yvelinoise du medef
l'organisation patronale qui a profité
de la soirée pour tenir son assemblée
générale puis son conseil
d'administration
au programme l'élection du nouveau
président du medef yvin et de ses vice
présidents le chef d'entreprise zakaria
redit a été désigné il succède à
bertrand de créer en poste depuis 2011
pour son mandat de trois ans le néo
président s'est fixé six axes
prioritaires les principaux ils sont
présentés un onni cros de nicolas
d'andrus les axes prioritaires c'est les
adhésions parce qu'il faut développer
les adhésions également nous avons
l'animation des commissions
les commissions pour mener un certain
nombre de sujets comment développer un
business modèle respectueux de
l'environnement comment s'adapter aux
nouvelles technologies liées à la bleue
chain etc
nous avons également un autre axe
prioritaire qui celui de l'organisation
et du contrôle interne
parce que une organisation patronale
comme d'un autre doigt est éthique doit
respecter certaines règles doit
notamment défendre ce qu'on appelle
l'économie inclusive l'économie
inclusive c'est on laisse personne sur
le bord de la route
voilà donc tous ces thèmes là qui vont
être un peu notre priorité
dans un peu plus d'une semaine c'est
noël moment de féerie est bien appréciée
des petits et grands avec les
traditionnelles sapin et décoration et
mais gare aux incendies dont le risque
est accru en cette période on en parle
avec le lieutenant colonel sébastien
frémont bonsoir bonsoir chef du
groupement prevention 10 10 78 c'est le
service départemental d'incendié et de
secours des yvelines en ces temps de
fêtes de fin d'année les interventions
des pompiers pour des incendies
domestiques
est ce qu'elles sont en augmentation
alors en fait le nombre d' incendies
domestiques
il ya une relation plus ou moins directe
avec la température plus le temps et
effroi et plus le risque de danger
d'incendié domestique augmente parce que
les gens se chauffent plus donc
davantage recours à des appareils de
chauffage et de ce fait potentiellement
des risques d'incendié plus importants
apparaissent en période hivernale nous
ça veut dire on l'expliquent cette
augmentation par des facteurs à risque
ce qui sont plus nombreux la ligne en
plus voilà les sapins qui sont très
inflammables il ya aussi un manque de
vigilance aussi de la part de certaines
personnes
c'est à dire que l'esprit festif parfois
fait qu'on fait peut-être un petit peu
moins attention à des éléments
finalement de base j'ai envie de dire
pour pour éviter qu'un sinistre ne
survienne et effectivement
du coup il est bon de rappeler un
certain nombre de précautions et de
règle de bon sens c'est important de
faire de la prévention
en cette période dans la prévention de
la sensibilisation j'ai envie de dire du
public et tout particulièrement des
enfants vos auditeurs ce soir s'il ya un
message à passer c'est bel et bien de
faire attention à vos enfants à nos
enfants parce que parfois quelques
minutes et secondes même d'inattention
un enfant en bas âge va jouer avec des
allumettes si elles sont à portée de
main ou un briquet et pour peu qu'ils
jouent à proximité du sapin et
malheureusement ça peut être le drame en
quelques secondes justement le premier
danger vient du sapin ou l'installer
dans la maison
la première règle c'est de l'installer
le plus loin possible j'ai envie de dire
d'une cheminée à foyer ouvert lorsqu'il
y en a une dans le salon parce que en
fonction des essences de bois le bois
qui brûle parfois peut produire des
escarbilles enflammé qui sont projetés
en dehors du foyer
et si le sapin se trouve dans un
périmètre relativement réduit
malheureusement c'est escarbilles peut
arriver sur le sapin et l'enflammé quasi
instantanément à sympa qui brûle c'est
en 10 secondes c'est une torchère et
l'idéal c'est de le maintenir aussi
hydrater alors dans la mesure du
possible placer un torchon mouillé sous
le sapin ou peut être une coupelle qui
permet de l'hydrater parce qu'un
assassin passe à sympathique pardon est
encore plus inflammable c'est ça tout
particulièrement j'ai envie de dire les
épicéas aujourd'hui de plus en plus on
voit les gens ont recours à des sapins
dit norman qui sont plus résistants à la
chaleur et parce que les épines se
tiennent mieux est de ce fait résiste
plus potentiellement aux risques
d'incendié
mais les épicéas tout particulièrement
effectivement il convient de mettre au
pied un linge humide afin de retarder
finalement l'assèchement des épines
parce que vraiment l'épicéa con ça
s'enflamme c'est de l'ordre de 5 à 10
secondes et c'est une torchère et c'est
un moment aussi on a envie d'allumer des
bougies dans sa maison voilà c'est beau
la bougie sa part fument aussi bref
plein de raison de les mettre
elle est aussi la vigilance à avoir sur
sur ses bougies tout particulièrement
j'ai envie de dire dans notre
département puisque en 2002 à
saint-nom-la-bretèche un drame familial
des enfants des adolescents réunis dans
une
dans une maison et puis ils font la fête
certainement consomme un petit peu
d'alcool puis s'endorment en laissant
des bougies décoratives brûlé toute la
nuit
et malheureusement au petit matin c'est
le drame les bougies finissent par
enflammer ce sur quoi elle était posée
et produisent un incendie au rez de
chaussée et de cet incendie
on relèvera une jeune adolescente de 17
ans décédée à l étage parce qu'elle n'a
pas pu tout simplement s'échapper avant
que le feu ne prenne une ampleur une
ampleur et surtout la fumée la toxicité
des fumées qui a gagné laitages et qui
ont fait que cette pauvre jeune fille
est décédée
donc ce drame qui est partie toute la
réflexion sur la loi qui impose
aujourd'hui d'avoir un détecteur de
fumée dans sa maison d'ailleurs c'est
aussi le moment de vérifier son option
détecteur de fumée est complètement en
effet il ya une loi de 2010 qui est la
loi dit d'ailleurs pierre mangin d'aidé
ciblée d'un député des yvelines à cette
époque qui impose que chaque logement en
france soient pourvus au moins d'un
détecteur autonome avertisseur de fumée
ça sauve des vies
ça coûte une dizaine d'euros est la
seule bonne question j'ai envie de se
dire j'ai envie de dire malheureusement
c'est se poser la question est ce que la
ville mes enfants la vie de mon conjoint
vos plus ou moins 10 euros
la cc vos auditeurs ont la réponse à
cette question est en tout état de cause
c'est la loi il faut absolument
installer un détecteur chez soi ça sauve
des vies
un dernier mot sur l'installation
électrique forcément avec la présence de
guirlandes lumineuses décoration est
aussi décoration sein de la crèche ça va
multiplier les branchements électriques
laquelle vigilance il faut avoir sur sur
cette espèce éviter d'avoir recours à
des multiprises en trop grand nombre et
surtout à brancher trop d'appareils sur
une même multiprise parce que ça risque
d'occasionner en fait des surchauffes et
ce sont ces surchauffe lorsque le
courant va forcer pour passer d'un
conducteur à un autre qu'il va
occasionner des surchauffes et cette
surchauffe et potentiellement à
l'origine d'un début d'incendié puisque
la chaleur risque de mettre le feu à
l'isolant en plastique qui va entourer
le conducteur et pour peu qu'on ait soit
1 un tissu un rideau à proximité et a
fortiori malheureusement un sapin est là
bien sûr le drame c'est le drame assuré
quoi bien merci pour tous ces bons
conseils sébastien vraiment je rappelle
que vous êtes le chef du groupement
prévention au sein d'us 10,78 le service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
des yvelines merci beaucoup aux prix
petite pause de culture est là présent
dans ce journal aux kurdes et carré
saint louis à versailles cet espace est
cet espace est resté fermé trois ans le
cube est un nouveau lieu dédié à des
expositions en ce moment d'ailleurs
c'est une expo saint-exupéry le seigneur
des sables qui a pris place le reportage
de mathilde et demi en 1766 à versailles
sont construits les carrés de saint
louis un édifice qui accueillera des
abreuvoirs une fontaine d'eau potable
mais aussi un château d'eau au temps de
louis 15 la mairie récupérera le
bâtiment dans les années 30 qui
deviendra un cabinet d'architecte
aujourd'hui le cube est devenu un nouvel
espace dédié à l'art
ça faisait donc pas mal d'années que cet
espace était
et est entre guillemets abandonné et
donc là on est en train de leur
transformer je dirais en lieu d'accueil
en lieu d'exposition
donc ça permet comme ça de revivifier à
la fois la place et de revivifier en
plus je dirais le quartier qui demande
un clément de coussan avant d'en faire
une salle d'exposition le cube a été
fermé pendant trois ans toute l'année la
galerie recevra différents artistes pour
des expositions mais aussi des ateliers
pour les enfants et des ateliers lecture
et donc versailles et ne connaissent pas
un terreau de cieux tout le monde passe
devant sans savoir ce qu'il en est et
c'est un lieu qui est vraiment atypique
avec une architecture moderne à
l'intérieur alors que le bâtiment est
vraiment du xviie à ses anciens depuis
le début du mois de décembre
quarante dessins sur la vie de
saint-exupéry fait par l'artiste cédric
fernandes sont proposés au public
dans cette nouvelle adresse culturel et
dans cette exposition sont proposés des
dessins originaux
ce sont les véritables planches de
l'artiste avec laquelle il a travaillé
pour faire donc ces trois volumes de
saint-exupéry on y retrouve évidemment
le monde de l'aviation
voilà tous les éléments autour de
saint-exupéry ils sont proposés à la
foire en dessin noir et blanc mais aussi
des illustrations couleur l'exposition
saint-exupéry le seigneur des sables est
disponible jusqu'au 28 décembre au cube
un événement solidaire c'était samedi à
maurepas l'association ads banny a
organisé sa soirée de gala deux invités
pour revenir sur cet événement sény
sylla bonsoir président de cette
association et ses coûts fadiga bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes membre actif de cette
association alors hadès je précise que
ça veut dire aide au développement à
l'éducation et à la santé est bannie
c'est un village du sénégal qui est
situé dans la région de tabac kunda déjà
présenté nous ce village est bannie
israël convenait de dire donc c'est donc
c'est pas d'israël la compagnie israël
donc c'est en village qui se situe dans
la région de tambacounda exactement au
nord du sénégal donc
voilà il a death donc aide au
développement à l'éducation à la santé
de banier ça a été créé un 2014 pour
subvenir aux besoins du village où on
est d'origine
mais avant tout ça les objectifs de
l'association cdd à des projets sur
place des francs et puis voilà qu'on me
l'a dit et souvenirs aux besoins du
village et pourquoi du coup ce village
vous êtes vous même originaire de ce
village de bani c'est le village dont
est originaire en fait du sénégal et son
village qui en paul ouin arrêtent des
capitaux fin de la capitale du capital
régional d'un président qui est en bacs
honda donc c'est une région en face à
une commune qui est très diminue donc
voilà ça sent la région tabac kunda dont
la capitale a le même nom c'est la ville
de taza goodman
c'est un lieu qui on va dire ans pour un
cave et dans le sénégal on va dire on
n'est pas très reconnue par le
gouvernement
il va nous nous sommes en train de faire
des efforts manifestez montrer à au
gouvernement sénégalais qu'on est
présent
voilà pour prendre le glaçage
considération expérience avec tous les
honneurs qu'on a fait à cette fois on
invite donc aussi là et pas mal de gens
très connue au sénégal doit pour qu'ils
puissent reconnaître et quelles sont les
urgences si je puis dire sur place quels
sont les projets qu'il faut développer
sur place un banni peu d'hydra comme
signifie c'est plutôt le développement
l'éducation et surtout la santé surtout
la santé de queue qui est très important
parce que souvent quand je disais donc
on est loin de la capitale régionale
laquelle tambacounda est encore plus
loin de la capitale
on va l'amener à dire du sénégal
monsieur sénégal par don égal et de
dakar que l'hôpital fait 1 500 décès en
centre de santé qui est là bas mais
souvent quand vous savez que ya beaucoup
beaucoup de domaines communs et les
routes sont pas aussi bonnes
ils sont dès l'âge où on aime pas
d'ambulance pour transporter en cas
d'urgence il est malade vers verton
bakhoda donc notre combat c'est vraiment
l'éducation santé et le développement
qui est de vrais projets à développer
sur place pourquoi justement ça vous
tient à coeur
tout en étant en france de continuer à
contribuer pour pour ce village dont
vous êtes originaire déjà comme on est
originaire de la touche j'ai vécu là-bas
moi j'ai alors suivi sensibilité voilà
donc je suis né ici mais j'ai grandi là
bas donc je sais comment ça se passe et
je vous dis docu ça me tient vraiment à
coeur de souvenirs au beau jeu donc
c'est un peu et malheureusement tout
seul faux pas est la seule solution
c'est de créer une association ici
commence avec les gens qui sont
d'origine de la regarder derrière ceux
originaires du sénat iphone de balle
israël exactement donc au port subvenir
aux besoins donc voilà là tuez-le m'a
donc on est quand même en collaboration
avec le maire du
la commune vi nations et pourront
centres de santé c'est le projet fort en
ce moment c'est ce centre de santé a
banni donc je rappelle que l'association
a été créée en 2014
si on revient déjà sur aussi sur la
soirée la soirée de gala que vous avez
tenu donc c'était à maurepas lors
l'association est basée à trappes mais
vous avez organisé votre soirée à
maurepas deuxième édition c'est
important de proposer cette soirée
justement pour récolter des fonds
oui ce soir etc et kiên moins de
recherche en fait on va dire d'argent
pour subvenir au besoin d'user donc la
clé la salle à mon repas parce que sur
ce qu'on trouve à trappes en fait c'est
des salles qui sont ouverts jusqu'à
minuit et nous parler les gens qui
viennent de partout de l'été pour
compliquer de fermer à minuit donc c'est
pour ça on appris la salle à maurepas et
bien sûr oui c'est moins de comment
s'appelle de recherche de fonds pour
subvenir au besoin à un moment festif et
c'est ceci solidaire du coup cette
soirée si nous ce soir est solide et
solidaire bien sûr mais on fait pas que
kolo gala on a déjà fait des tournois de
foot des barbecues à la base de loisirs
pour récolter en fait on cherche toutes
les sortes de
des d'activité l'été pour récolter le
maximum de fonds très bien et si vous
faites le bilan sur cette soirée
commença s'est déroulée cette deuxième
édition 10 ans a nié que l'année
précédente
c'était une soirée on va dire un spécial
on a vraiment acquis pas moins du monde
on était très content et je pense que
sincèrement aussi sa dette vous avez des
idées du des montants récoltés pendant
soirée au point encore il faut faire les
comptages là comment s'appellent les
trésoreries sont sur le comment
s'appelle sûr de les dépenser 2 les
bénéfices on a eu en fait donc on
pourrait donner des montages traumatisme
est pas défini en tout cas définitive
plus tôt donc voilà mais en tout cas
comme je disais donc oui ça a été une
soirée réussie sans en faire un peu côté
humanitaire et tout ça est coté aussi
populaire par rapport à l'année dernière
donc cette année on a eu du bon pour
plus de monde qu'en cas l'année dernière
et c'est en tout cas ça nous a vraiment
un moment touché pour les gens qui
qu'ils nous tiennent cois et on peut
continuer à soutenir votre association
continue à rester informé sur votre
association se rendant sur la page
facebook qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci sény sylla merci ceku fadiga que
vous êtes membre actif de l'association
président de l'association addes est
bannie et je rappelle un qui aide à
plusieurs projets dans ce village bani
israël et c'est au sénégal merci à vous
deux autre événement à vocation
solidaire un stage de kung fu
traditionnels se déroulait hier dimanche
à villepreux un rendez-vous au tarif
libre pour évier aider les réfugiés
tibétains accueilli jusqu'à jeudi
dernier dans la commune on revient sur
ce stage avec manon varaldo ghislain
kuen vie à taiwan
il s'est déplacé spécialement pour
enseigner le kung fu traditionnel à
villepreux
c'est difficile parce que ça a l'air
facile quand on le voit il n'y a pas de
sauts il n'y a pas de choses très très
spectaculaire ce qui est difficile c'est
que ça demande beaucoup beaucoup de
force dans les jambes puisque on va
utiliser les jambes les hanches pour
tourner pour frapper ce qui est
difficile aussi c'est apprendre à
respirer quand on frappe et il faut être
un petit peu souple cet expert 3e dan
international transmet les clés du kung
fu aux cinquante participants
il est le représentant européen de m
lumengo oui je suis un amoureux des arts
martiaux plus particulièrement du kung
fu
je commence à me diversifier à
diversifier un peu
mais de base vient du kung fu et donc du
beau show que j'ai pratiqué à pendant
pas mal de temps
en parallèle de la boxe est hélas
aujourd'hui personnellement c'est un
grand jour pour moi parce que je
retrouve énormément de gens justement de
ce milieu c'est à la fois une journée de
retrouvailles
une journée de partage est aussi une
journée d'entraînement donc je suis venu
à la fois pour les gens et pour
l'entraînement je suis extrêmement
contente de pouvoir rpt pratiques et des
bases de d'arts martiaux traditionnels
chinois
sachant que c'est quelque chose qui est
de plus en plus difficiles à trouver
y compris en région parisienne y compris
en france et que même même en chine ça
commence à disparaître un peu cette
journée était organisée par pro fight
pour aider les réfugiés tibétains de
ville reparti jeudi
le tarif de ce stage était libre on
connaît bien la cause des tibétains
et on était particulièrement sensible à
leur venue et
on a voulu faire un moment de partage
avec eux malgré qu'ils sont partis jeudi
dernier à manta ville les recettes
perçues lors de ce stage iront
intégralement à l'association acr au
profit des réfugiés tibétains aller tout
de suite les résultats sport du week-end
avec michael et demi d'euros bonsoir
journalistes aux sports de la rédaction
du football pour commencer avec le
championnat de régionale 2 un derby y
vino a pour terminer l'année 2019 quoi
de mieux trappe recevait l'équipe 2 de
versailles à l'occasion de la 10e
journée de régionale 2 après une fin de
match à suspense les trappistes arrache
finalement le match nul score final un
but partout on écoute les réactions on
est rentré en deuxième mi temps avec un
visage un peu plus conquérant et on
avait à coeur de
de ramener au minimum ce point du match
nul c'était un match engagé contre
pour les deux équipes qui jouent le
maintien savait que ça allait être un
combat assez difficile qui plus est avec
un terrain très compliqué donc le
résultat nul me semble logique
après ce résultat trap est toujours sous
la menace d'une relégation en fin de
saison les trappistes pointe à la 10e
place sur 12 équipes engagées
mais l'équipe termine l'année sur une
note positive depuis le retour sur le
banc dit chardy trappe reste sur une
série de deux victoires et deux nuls en
quatre matches et le championnat
reprendra le 2 janvier le 19 janvier
pendant le championnat de régionale 2
avec un match face à ozoir on parle
maintenant handball lors du bilan pour
montigny le bretonneux sur cette
première partie de saison
l'heure du bilan jouer ce week-end le
dernier match de l'année du côté de
montigny-le-bretonneux des féminines ont
fait ont fait plaisir à leurs supporters
présents en leur offrant une belle
victoire contre les premières du
classement tall carantec le score 35 à
28 cette victoire permet à l'équipe de
terminer troisième du classement avant
noël on écoute le président il nous
dresse son bilan de cette première
partie de saison on aurait pu faire
mieux on aurait pu tout gagné on aurait
pu tout gagner mais on a eu également de
travers on sait on a rencontré l'équipe
d'ici paris de réserve où on fait
l'équipe pro ne jouait pas et avec des
descentes de joueuse professionnelle qui
nous ont pas fait que du bien c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
montigny le bretonneux reprendra le 5
janvier prochain contre marcel verne
merci michael pour ces résultats et on
en retrouvera d'autres encore dans votre
émission le cetud sport dans un instant
sur tv 78 et vous dresserez aussi voilà
c'est la dernière émission de cette
année 2010 9,1 bilan sportif des club
yvelinois
ce sera tout à l'heure sur tv 78 avant
de refermer ce journal le point sur vos
conditions de circulation demain mardi
dans les transports plusieurs syndicats
je vous le disais au début de cette
édition seront mobilisés contre la
réforme des retraites sncf et ratp
conseille est d'ores et déjà de ne pas
se rendre en gare de demain les
perturbations seront nombreuses un
transilien sur cinq annoncés le trafic
de la ligne u sera de nouveau totalement
à l'arrêt pas de train entre les gares
de la défense et de la verrière pour la
ligne n 1 train toutes les 30 minutes
entre rambouillet paris montparnasse aux
heures de pointe
amplitude horaire légèrement réduites
tout comme sur l'ex plaisir grignon pour
les lignes de rer pas ou peu de
changements un train sur deux en heure
de pointe sur le rer rer à un train sur
trois pour le rer b l'interconnexion est
toujours interrompu en gare du nord
enfin aucun train ne circulera encore
sur le rer c entre paris austerlitz et
les gares de versailles chantiers et
versailles rive gauche et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines note également
que le trafic du thé 6 passant par
vélizy et viroflay sera réduit de moitié
un tram sur 2 est des retards et
perturbations sont également probable
sur le réseau des skis bus voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci d'avoir suivi
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]